and finally new rule before we spread
democracy around the world america has
to figure out how to spread water around
america
we don't uh
we don't know if afghanistan ever wanted
democracy but i've been to burbank i
know they drink water
but for how much longer
our new normal is never-ending
life-threatening drought and wildfires
in the west and in the east the opposite
that's the extreme rainfall area what i
call the cardi b region because
[Applause]
if you live there your ass is going to
be wet
while rivers here in the west dry up the
east coast will be getting brand new
rivers like this one in manhattan
yeah if you've never been on the subway
that's not how it's supposed to look
and i got to tell you when i saw that
video i think i had the same thought as
everyone here in california can we have
some
whenever i watch flood footage from
anywhere i feel like a girl with no ass
staring at kim kardashian
just once i'd like to be the dumbass
whose car stalls out in the intersection
for more on this let's go to me with the
weather
okay on this side of the country it
doesn't rain anymore ever
and on this side of the country they're
drowning
now here's sport
thank you
thank you very much oh please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but you know this is not an imponderable
quandary like cold fusion or why they
can't find a host for jeopardy
as the general manager of the southern
nevada water authority once said one
man's flood control is another man's
water supply
does anyone see where i'm going with
this
that it would be a giant win-win if we
just built pipelines from where the
water is
to where the water
isn't
i
i'm not a civil engineer but if we can
extract shale oil from tar sands two
miles below the frozen surface of canada
and pipe it to louisiana why not water
water
is a lot
water is a lot easier to get than oil
i've heard there are places where it
literally falls from the sky
[Applause]
now in the past when i brought up the
idea of a water pipeline i was deterred
from pressing the point by the
conventional wisdom that this has been
proposed and studied and it's just not
feasible
but i looked into the details and
tonight i'd like to call [ __ ] on
that
what's not feasible is us
this idea is only a non-starter because
of petty political squabbles insane
levels of graft and red tape it's
completely doable and in fact has been
proposed many times by serious people
availability of water is not the problem
to the east of us flooding
to the west a giant reservoir called the
pacific ocean
oh yes the ocean
did you know that israel gets most of
its water from the ocean from
desalinization why can't we do
desalination if israel does we have jews
here
i'm sure they can figure it out we have
lots of smart people the problem isn't
one of know-how either it's will and
selfishness and greed
think about it logically why would it
really be harder to get water through a
pipe than oil the u.s already has 2.6
million miles of pipelines to transport
oil and natural gas and hazardous
liquids and they are all really easier
to move than water is a water pipeline
really more of an engineering challenge
than we built railroads through the
rocky mountains
or laid the transatlantic cable or made
the panama canal
or put a man on the moon which
even if you think was faked you have to
admit pulling off a prank like that
would be in itself quite a remarkable
achievement
moving water is not impossible it can be
done others have done it the romans did
it with first century technology some of
their aqueducts are still in use
the incas the minoans the egyptians lots
of ancient people did it and let's not
forget moses parting the red sea
china does it now
beijing depends on water that is
provided by their massive south north
water transfer project which was begun
in december of 2002 and of course being
china
completed the next day
[Applause]
but in america we don't even start
because we know
why would it be any different from any
other ambitious project
like afghanistan
but always just turns into a giant money
grab
here in california we know we can't
house the homeless because the cost of a
single unit has risen to 750 thousand
dollars
we tried to build high-speed rail they
finally pulled the plug on that because
the cost got so out of hand that's why
nothing ever gets done in this country
because so much [ __ ] is built into
everything that it's a boondoggle before
it starts
this is our tragic flaw
the ever ballooning costs the inflated
contracts
the back scratching the kickbacks the
private contractors the padded expense
accounts the layers of consultants
the permits the fees the environmental
impact statements the lawsuits the
lawyers the lobbyists the red tape
graft on a scale untameable
but 78 million people live in the west
what do we do with the not so distant
future when they're all water refugees
the colorado river supplies 40 million
people with the water they need to live
and it's drying up
those people can't all get in covered
wagons head east and move back in with
their parents
you